the battle for Christmas number one is a
British music tradition to be at the top
of the charts on Christmas Day is to
have a place in history sometimes
serious pop acts have managed it the
Spice Girls did it three times in a row
sometimes it was more of a mid 90s fever
dream some of the importance of the
Christmas number one comes from the UK
music industry's official charts which
are based purely on music sales not on
airplay
every pop music radio station in Britain
could play a track every hour on the
hour
and it wouldn't make a bit of difference
if no-one walked into a music shop open
their wallets and actually bought the
physical single or later paid to
download a digital file that doesn't
really work these days if you go back to
1952 when the charts were first launched
guy called Percy Dickens basically to
get on the phone and call up you know 20
of his mates you worked in record shops
and just ask them you know what records
were popular that particular week and it
was as basic as that so for most of the
history of the chart so you know what
we've done is we've counted sales
because that's the way that consumers
music fans have been able to access
their music every year hundreds of music
acts released novelty Christmas singles
hoping to be the one that makes it
through the track and gets to the top of
the charts and almost all of them fail
although it's pretty heartwarming when
they do succeed because it usually means
that the winner of The X Factor has been
beaten down into second place and people
seem to enjoy it when Simon Cowell
doesn't win but calculating the numbers
now is trickier than it used to be for
the last two and a half years we've been
not just counting sales but also adding
streams in there as well we convert the
streams to sales by dividing the streams
by a hundred and then we put it all
together the hundred is essentially a
kind of an estimate of the of the value
of the stream versus the value of a
download we're actually changing that
from the beginning of 2017 to 150
because what we're seeing is a massive
shift in terms of the number of streams
that are being generated and the number
of sales that are being made as well
Spotify and Apple music diesel and tidal
Amazon have both
Amazon Prime music and Amazon
Unlimited's we count those as well there
are other smaller services on top of
that but begin it pretty much any audio
streaming service you'll be using we
count you'll notice something missing
from that list of streaming services the
official UK chart doesn't count YouTube
views inferior YouTube could track music
use but it can't tell whether you're
listening to a song because you're there
to listen to music or just because
someone has decided to soundtrack their
multi million view video with Bing
Crosby's white Christmas we've never
counted video and consumption of video
and we're not doing so now that said
obviously we're always talking about it
it's a big debate in the industry about
whether it should and it shouldn't count
that may change at some point in the
future and but not not quite for now I
don't know who's going to be Christmas
number one this year and neither do the
folks here at the official UK charts
company least as I record this a lot
suspect they've probably got a pretty
good idea by now at 5:40 p.m. on
December the 23rd BBC Radio 1 will make
the announcement and at least for this
year someone will still be entering the
history books
[Music]